ce chat aux couleurs de l'Ukraine tire
puis avance rapidement dans le sud les
trop ukrainiennes continuent de regagner
du terrain il y a encore quelques jours
l'ennemi russe occupait cette zone
le fait qu'ils aient laissé des
munitions
et qu'une partie de la poudre était
sabotée et pour qu'on ne puisse pas
l'utiliser prouve qu'il s'enfuyait très
rapidement
ses soldats espèrent atteindre la ville
de Kerson d'ici l'hiver une
contre-offensive qui se poursuit aussi
dans l'Est certaines villes comme bac
mout sont au cœur des combats depuis le
printemps la majorité des habitants ont
fui ce qui reste doivent traverser la
ville en ruine pour trouver de la
nourriture au risque de leur vie
ici la là-bas
des armes automatiques
on ne sait jamais est-ce que les Russes
vont tirés ensuite
un périple bien trop difficile pour ce
couple qui vit un enfer le mari est
atteint d'un cancer il peut à peine
bouger
je ne sais pas comment on va survivre à
l'hiver ni combien de temps il va vivre
on n'a pas de gaz pas d'électricité pas
d'eau depuis trois mois je dois
récupérer l'autre pluie et l'utiliser
pour cuisiner de l'autre côté du pays
l'Ouest était jusque-là relativement
épargné par les bombardements mais visé
par des frappes russes lundis et hier
les habitants de le vif vivent aussi
sans électricité
lundi il n'y a pas eu d'électricité de
la journée le courant n'a été rétabli à
minuit j'ai aussi réussi à récupérer de
l'eau et après une nouvelle explosion
mardi matin nous sommes de nouveau sans
eau ni électricité
selon le ministre ukrainien de l'énergie
la Russie a frappé environ un tiers des
infrastructures énergétiques du pays
depuis lundi